l everyone and welcome to binge-watch a
weekly go to show for everything to do
with TV movies and of course streamed
friendly entertainment I'm Lucy James
still pining over the end of Fargo
season 2 joining me this week as always
is captain of the USS gamespot Dave do
it thank you sir oh goodness uh and let
me tell you a little bit about anime
tomorrow same anime he does this a lot
seriously in the office every day so
guys we're coming right off the back of
San Diego comic-con so we are spoiled
for choice for things to talk about but
we've gone through it with a fine-tooth
comb to find you the biggest stories I
mean to be honest I spent most of the
weekend looking at the incredible
cosplay particularly the overwatch stuff
and the game of thrones stuff you can
find some galleries and videos on
gamespot com but without further ado
let's get to it
all right we're gonna kick things off
with all the big DC news so luckily
tomorrow here is our resident DC expert
time what with a big takeaways from the
sea air show there was a lot so they had
a DC / war number of his panel and like
I said there was a lot in there so I'm
gonna channel the Speed Force to get
through this quickly the first thing
that they showed was the debut trailer
for Wonder Woman which was excellent I
know if you guys saw it I'm assuming you
didn't yeah did you think of it the
action scenes looks like there was
intense as Batman V Superman but didn't
have Superman in it so they were good
anyone oh no I really like the look of
it um because i thought when i was
watching batman vs superman wonder woman
was one of the redeeming qualities of
that movie and I was excited to see what
they would do and I thought gal Godot
was a gray Wonder Woman so I'm really
excited also to get Chris Pine Chris
Pine get him at the enterprise different
different franchise yeah i really liked
and what I noticed was it kind of what
what made her memorable as a character
in Batman V Superman was also kind of
what made the trailer for Wonder Woman
quite memorable the badass Wonder Woman
like she did a lot of punching dudes and
she did it really well she'd like a no
scope 420 in the air I went with a bow
and arrow and I was like COD player
definitely and like they were still look
like a heart to it as well like you know
she met chris pine's character and their
relationship is going to be a key part
of their you know the movie going
forward humor color it was like the
first trailer that kind of like denoted
a shift in kind of tone and style for
the DC movies very you know moving away
from the darkness from the bit kind of
po-faced ya know a little one is still
pretty dark yeah but into like the
Marvel you know stuff's going on it's
all really bad but you're gonna have a
little quip here and there yeah I like
the last line where she helped the
secretary be a little more woke what is
a secretary I go where he tells me to go
and I do what u tells me to do yeah what
a [ __ ] from that's called slavery I
really like her fantastic ladies are you
into I did mine so more of that kind of
shift in tone we got to see in the
Justice League trailer so finally the
squad is together no shouldn't call them
the squad cuz that mean legally elected
decent league is being put
Batman is continuing his efforts to you
know assemble the greatest superhero
group in DC Universe ikishi but I didn't
like other like franchises into this the
Guardians oh god yeah so what did you
think of that trailer I as a huge fan of
the Justice League it made me very very
happy to see these characters come
together and the dynamic seems to be one
we're familiar with the kind of reminded
me of the one eyed reading comics or
even like in the animated series you get
like carefree but also kind of a bit
vulnerable flash you get you know Batman
and you know Wonder Woman's dynamic it
seems it's a little lighter it's not
like the one they had with you know
between batman or superman in the movie
which was just the can we talk a little
bit about Aquaman yes my days I think
because everyone's made so much fun of
him they are they throwing it that much
further into the other end like even
made fun of for years it's make him the
most badass thing about the whole
trailer so bad he was unbelievable I
thought I thought flash as well clearly
the comedic chops of the squad League
klase squad Suicide Squad but that was
one analyte and again it's like doing
the Marvel thing quick quick quip yeah
every 10 seconds or so well i don't i
don't think it's gonna be as much like
marvelous because marvel they build legs
like a lot more around comedy i think
this is going to be like the little
personality shining through an Aquaman
seems to me he you know he's always he's
always his issue is that he has to
balance his kind of allegiance from
responsibility to the land above versus
you know his own Kingdom and I think
that's key to what his angst is about I
think if there's going to be any angst
in the movie it's going to be mainly
focused around him and which I am okay
with also him standing from the wave
while it's just like crashing into him
was bit much well I think I didn't like
though is how in the trailer everyone
kind of got their little introduction
and some some bands and in cyborgs just
like I'm here and I'm and Cyborg was
there too yeah I just hope that doesn't
reflect on how his characters gonna be
the movie like yes I bought some
sunshine man yeah he's key to that the
league in terms of getting stuff done
like he can open pores and he's
basically the information guy but he's
also very very important to like the
powerhouse so I hope they give
equal amount of attention the next one
we got see was a suicide squad which is
out in a couple of weeks I am continuing
to like be surprised at how much I'm
excited about it it seems like the first
I think they're trying to position it as
the big movie that you know the kind of
really really pivots on what DC and
Warner's movies are going to be like so
we had Batman V Superman and people are
like man this is a bit boring and it's a
bit too angsty I'm a bit of an apologist
for for those movies but I think this is
the start of them saying like we can do
fun movies to look at all the color
we've got the cervelo kids yeah check
out our rick ross song but yeah you guys
can I know a lot of people that are like
I'm done now with DC I'm full Marvel are
you guys being drawn back into i very
much am being drawn back into it by The
Suicide Squad yeah for sure I wanted
something there's a bit more fun
especially after like the biggest thing
was the dark knight previously bit of a
palate cleanser in the way of suicides
got to be good and add some really good
music in that trailer yeah i'm twenty
one pilots yeah I will see Suicide Squad
I'm not like jumping up and down to see
it i think it has a potential to be good
and I hope it is good at the point I'm
at the point now where I've just been so
oversaturated by the marketing I'm just
like oh it's another Suicide Squad
trailer like it's a character trailer a
character trailer another trailer I'm
just like I done now just what I don't
see it okay I'm I'd rather take the
hairs the character here's a character
like constantly seeing pictures of
characters then them really digging into
like this is the story because I hate
your own trailers do that especially for
superheroes the movies because
traditionally they're not overly complex
so like you know just keep it brief just
show me characters move on I'm around
that so coming out of comic con how do
we think DC's looking I think they're
looking a lot better than they did
before and after Batman vs Superman and
all the other Superman movies I think it
shows that someone there is listening
and understands you know what they need
to do to change and someone there's also
looking at Marvel and being like day
they seem to have this nail down maybe
we should borrow it and I think
someone's raining in zack snyder as well
and being like you aren't as good as you
think you are relax
and getting some other people and
reshoots and giving more money for that
stuff is it's encouraging I'm more
encouraging now than I have been before
yeah I'm on board of that like you like
you said it's that they're taking
lessons from Marvel they've realized
that the dark gritty stuff isn't going
to last forever that people are going to
get bored of that and I imagine that's
probably half the reason why sua squad
got the green light they were like okay
let's let's at least try something silly
something fun something you know a bit
wild so hopefully if that pays off we'll
see more cool different stuff from DC
because they've they've got they've got
the back catalogue of interesting
characters I hope they have some of my
favorite yeah they've just never been
brave enough to explore them so heavily
now they they will be Booster Gold movie
don't know who that is okay well that
was DC Dave what did Marvel have to show
well Marvel obviously put up a good
fight as well there's plenty to get
excited about from there their offerings
first up one of the coolest showings
what I well from my opinion was Doctor
Strange trailer there was definite
inception vibes with the whole earth
pending yeah I thought it was inception
meets sort of matrix e meets quantum
break hmm I mean I'd watch that movie
anyway yeah but it's um like personally
I'm excited to see Marvel jump into the
the realms of the magic and fantastical
we've we've done dug grave done superior
teams we've done space and different
galaxies hmm let's throw some magic
about man yeah I think I think they kind
of need to do that now right with all
the stuff that is happening on netflix
and with iron fist and defenders and
that kind of stuff they need to start
exploring more of the other flavors of
the Marvel Universe I think we can only
take so much of the Avengers fighting
amongst each other and then fighting a
really weird like one off yeah one off
like a where they held it was a fing
Fang Foom but yeah I think they need to
start exploring that stuff more and I
think dr. strange is good because it's
doing that by salih kind of like a
character study of that character and
kind of his flaws and what he needs to
become the sorcerer supreme and that
kind of stuff so and his bad American
accent yeah so I get from here to there
and his amazing magnetic cape did you
see the goodness I need that hey I got
up straight away and try to do that with
my coat and just immediately pissed off
my what well I want to know
is what is the difference here to keep
and a cloak I think he's walking a fine
line I think yeah I think a cloak goes
over the front and the Cape is over your
shoulders just around the back but I
really like the look at the trailer yeah
tilda swinton obviously it's colorful
hanging on the side of a building yeah
any shopping I most race he looks good
on you he embodies what is the man
carries himself and from the TV side we
got to learn about dead of a season 3
it's happening hopefully better than
season to feast our eyes on the trailer
for luke cage which looked badass
excellent choice of music yep the
jumeirah trait is an ailing yeah they
shout out yeah we just hope they've got
one guy he's got like this amazing
Spotify playlist just goes it's just
called wu-tang clan just crawling bad
spell the best of you think um iron fist
looks pretty exciting as well I will
never be able to see him as anything
other than Loras Tyrell which is awful
yeah I like I mean they didn't show much
of you know that trailer light was just
me Danny but then in the defenders
trailer he said there was like who is
Danny R and yeah just like on as a
mystery or the defenders was very was
very teaser did the like the spelling
out the defenders in the kind of ransom
no scars you are by Nirvana as well yeah
eggs are the solid choice and at the end
you hear em stick what what sounds like
yes him um mystic obviously was
Daredevils ninja trainer blind dude so
that's further solidifies the group but
with won't know with four heroes stories
meeting now I'm interested to know what
the predictions are the series because
it's very hard to balance for massive
personalities i think yeah I think
they're gonna I think that sticks are
kind of presents kind of hints at who
they're fighting it's going to be the
hand right and the hand what we have is
any called before yeah free which it'll
confuse with a bad guys who changement
is ninja turtles so like and they're not
a kind of like one do type group they
when they come they come in for so it's
gonna be unloved them so I imagine it's
gonna be all so that's all of them oh
it's gonna be like the whole of New York
is covered in these handed dudes so we
need to split up and then they were just
get on the phone which other hand and
face time and stuff has no new good
skype logo in the corner yeah well by
you Lucy you excited for the defenders
I'm excited I'm also interested to see
like more heroes I feel like daredevil
season two I wasn't the biggest fan of
there was some bit like The Punisher was
incredible i absolutely loved him but I
felt like daredevil story I want him to
meet more characters like jessica jones
i Luke Cage yeah sure that and finally
we had the trailer for legion give it to
me now well Lucy's excited for it I
wasn't sure what to think of the teaser
but no cuz I've just come off the bat of
watching fargo and Noah Hawley who's the
guy who brought fire go to TV was
originally by the coen brothers like
that stud show is so Amelie good he's
got some of the same actors from it and
he's got Matthew Crawley from Downton
Abbey dad know it as the lead guy I'm I
mean well it's on net effect rather than
netflix yeah so it's not exactly clear
how we'll get see in the UK hopefully
likely Netflix yes yeah it follows David
hauler and deals with issues of holla
get dolla holla holla get your own TV
series that's a not using wu-tang holla
holla get dolla no but it deals with
things like schizophrenia mental health
and kind of combines his powers with all
these dealings as well really you know
who he is right he's Xavier son really
yeah we're of that wow that sounds make
sense though it's it's definitely got a
different vibe from what we've seen in
previous here right got more hair than
Xavier difference not define different
hairstyles but for merely impressions
from the trailer I'm into it I'm
anything that's given me a different
vibe and a palate cleanser from what
we've already seen yeah finally
something in the x-men universe we can
get excited about stop this is too soon
I am just quickly then have all the
Marvel's offerings we've talked about
what we haven't what are you most
excited about free agent and next 18
months coming from a captain marvel oh
god yeah fremont brie Larson yes I was
gonna be rad she's gonna be a weed
that's all there was Captain Marvel and
brie Larson same person but I'm on board
with that yeah that's what I'm excited
about I'm aboard captain marvel Legion
and iron fist and [ __ ] about this I'm
wu-tang clan lieutenant I relate with
anime
I guess finally from san diego comic-con
we got a look at the new Star Trek sort
of the ship we got a look at the ship
but I mean it's already causing a lot of
drams yeah because it does obviously
look very very different and it is not
an enterprise it's not enterprise at all
it's called the USS discovery NCC 1031
catchy which also me and we also find
out the name of the TV show is going to
be Star Trek discovery abbreviate to STD
I feel like what the thing is in America
they call it VD all right and then I
think they've gone from VD straight STI
whereas in the UK it's always always
been sexually transmitted diseases STD
sexually transmitted discussed want to
be the first person say this new star
trek is worse than STD first stop it no
give her chance I'm sure it's gonna be
excellent they had a big panel it was
quite disappointing actually because if
we were hoping to find out stuff on new
Star Trek we didn't get any caste or
anything but we did find out that it's
going to be set in the prime universe so
not the JJ Abrams alt timeline universe
which is quite cool and the ship itself
was dessert this is quite cool I've done
some digging everyone's recognizing it
like Ralph McQuarrie designed a
prototype ship that looked very much
like this back in the 70s for a star
trek movie that ended up getting canned
Ralph McQuarrie then went on to
basically create the look of Star Wars
Oh which is really cool and this is what
the discovery actually looks like it
looks like his old concept art for what
he did for star trek back in the 70s
which isn't it cool so people are trying
to figure out where discoveries going to
be set we're gonna find out more in
January but did you guys watch the
teaser what did you think I saw a bit of
it I'm always kind of I'm in an out with
Star Trek it's sometimes I watch it and
I'm like yeah this is great and but a
lot of times I'm just like it's the
pacing of it that kind of like I'm not
always on board I have to be in a
specific mood to really enjoy Star Trek
whereas something like Star Wars I can
get on board with tray away because if
you view that's been kind of me
but like federation and they just one
yeah unity and having said that I'm in
the mood for something a little more
mass effect flavored to watch yeah and
that's my kind of lens that I'm seeing
this through and so like yeah I'm
excited about it and I'm always willing
to give an opportunity I do like Star
Trek well the guy who's actually writing
it and is I think the co-creator is
Bryan Fuller who Dave you're watching
voyager at the minute this guy's written
a bunch of voyager bunch of deep space 9
do you think he can put his put his mark
on a new trick that's its kind of
concerning Spanish because much love
Voyager I'm like going through all the
Voyager again I kind of in the mood for
like a grittier Star Trek i know i said
before i'd like new kind of cleanser but
since then you did pushing daisies
admittedly not the gritty droll little
bit I know this come done but he's also
Darnell Hannibal pretty green the
american gods and the trailer for that
looks gritty gritty if it's if it's a
Star Trek where I'm gonna see like it
looks like an early design the ship so
i'm anticipating that I still at war
with the Klingons if I see some badass
like Federation troopers getting getting
gritty in the trenches with some
Klingons their batlets and stuff sounds
vaguely formula anything it's that I can
be sexual you just add an extra like
Vatel to the end of end of a word yes
three star trek I'd be into it bridgie
I'm trying to I'm trying to do it want
to get pretty with it no no no no no and
I mean other than comic-con news that
the one thing everyone's been talking
about is strange things on Netflix brand
new original series that i am currently
super super obsessed with guys you see
it i have seen it i've watched a couple
of episodes and i really like it how
much you in love with bob a lot i like
the kid with no teeth though yeah i
don't know that i haven't seen enough to
learn all their names yet but the kid
with no teeth is my MVP of everything
I've in a senior but irony I've got like
it was no teeth to look forward to and
there's another the little girl that
like there's an argument happening at
once fine and she's just like she's
great I mean there are obviously I think
the best thing about it for me is Winona
Ryder's star turn as Joyce buyers but if
you have been watching stranger things
and keep an eye out at youtube.com slash
game swap because i'm currently working
on a piece or it's basically
all the movies books I podcasts and
things you will like if you like
stranger things because that that show
is just steeped in references and things
from the late 70s mid 82 through the 80s
and it's so awesome yes spoiler there's
a ton of Stephen King in there he likes
it he loves it I love it too and I love
Stephen King wait like it's all okay
listen you I'm gonna this is your
homework for next week I'm gonna make
you watch it but that's all we got time
for this week on binge-watch thank you
very much for watching can find us on
twitter at least james games i'm at a
regular day and i'm at two more hey if
you liked the video make sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more and we will see
you next time
you